no one has tribal eyes America quite
like Barack Obama in the years of my
life the idea that Barack Obama is some
sort of Halcyon of uniting rhetoric is
absolute turd it's not true whatsoever
and then he said somewhere in here that
Congress he hoped would have the courage
not to do what's politically expedient
but to do deep in our heart what we know
is right he said Congress people should
quote recognize it takes little courage
to aid those who are already powerful
already comfortable already influential
it takes some courage to champion the
vulnerable and the sick and the infirm
those who often have no access to the
corridors of power this is such crap
every demagogue in history has said this
ok the idea that it takes courage to
champion the little guy
it takes no courage to champion the
little guy it also takes no courage to
champion the big guy you noted takes
courage to do to tell the truth to vote
the little guy and to the big guy the
idea that it takes courage to sit around
talking to how the poor have it rough
that does not take courage you know it
takes courage telling people stuff they
don't want to hear Kevin Williamson
wrote a great column over at National
Review over the weekend about how
there's an entire mentality that exists
in parts of the country where people
feel that they are passive observers in
their own life and not responsible for
any of the things that they do in their
own life so you know they are evicted
it's not that they did stuff to leave
them to being evicted they are evicted
or they have a bad job ok they don't
have a bad job they got a bad job
because they didn't do make good
decisions about their education in many
cases this idea that everybody is a
victim ok this is something that is
promulgated in politics the idea that it
takes courage to promulgate a victim
narrative about how some people in
America are screwing other people in
America that is not courage courage is
doing what Ted Cruz did in Iowa during
the last election cycle and campaigning
for the presidency in Iowa the first
state by saying I'm not going to give
you subsidies because ethanol is a
boondoggle that's political courage a
political courage is actually Donald
from saying to members of the black
community guys the problem here ain't
the police the problem here is the gangs
ok that takes political courage it takes
political courage to say things that are
not popular and it is always popular to
say oh look at the poor guy poor guys
getting screwed that's always the easy
thing to say for Obama to pretend
otherwise to pretend like oh he has
serious courage for saying that poor
people also have health care of course
poor people ought to have health care
everybody ought to have health care in a
free market system that's the only way
that poor people are ever going to be
able to afford good health care
everybody not ought to have health care
buddy ought to be able to have health
care that they can afford and work for
and don't demand at the point of gun
from somebody else freedom still matters
and quality of health care still matters
basically all that redistribution ISM
does is it freezes time and
redistributes resources
that's all research redistribution ISM
does socialism freezes what you have
right now and redistributes it and then
it starts to fade ok that's what happens
in medicine to socialism just freezes
things and then redistributes them free
markets grow things okay that's why it's
it's harsher it's a harder world in
capitalism than it is in socialism but
only in the short term it's certainly
not in the long term which is why we
live better now than we did twenty years
ago and socialist countries live worse
now than they did 30 years ago